[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
abend das neue jahr ist ja nun auch
schon neun tage alt die feiertage also
längst vorbei und trotzdem gibt es immer
noch schwierigkeiten an wirklich
verlässliche krone bzw omikron daten zu
kommen und jetzt ist ja auch eher wieder
wochenende mit dem üblichen melde verzug
sind erstaunlich dass wir auch zwei
jahre nach pandemie beginnen immer noch
mit digitalisierung und vernetzung von
ämtern zu kämpfen haben trotzdem ist
natürlich sichtbar wie am nikon durch
die republik zieht die sieben tage
incidents steigt weiterhin kräftig an
und liegt heute im bundesdurchschnitt
bei über 360 dem norden hat die omikron
variante bereits fest im griff eine
hebestreit berichtet
kiel heute morgen mitten in der stadt
ist eine wichtige fernwärmeleitung
geplatzt das heiße eingefärbt wasser
läuft aus tausende kinder frieren in
ihren wohnungen jetzt kommt es darauf an
dass die kritische infrastruktur schnell
repariert wird dafür muss trotz omikron
genügend personal bereitstehen
sie haben bereits vor einem jahr
angefangen die kritische infrastruktur
auch mit priorität durch zu impfen die
sind meistens auch gepustet das heißt
wenn sie heute sich infizieren dann
erkranken sie nicht mehr so stark lange
waren die institute zahl in den
schleswig holstein vergleichsweise
niedrig vielleicht hat man sich zu
sicher gefühlt corona und seinen
varianten mit weniger strikten maßnahmen
begegnen zu können die quittung kam nach
den feiertagen auf sylt und an anderen
orten im land hatten sich viele menschen
den diskotheken mit der omicron variante
infiziert trotz impfung müssen sich
tausende isoliere auch im familienkreise
schon zwei fälle gehabt von umgekommen
wenn wir das hier sieht den dithmarschen
was dafür sieht der zahl sind wir wieder
hier spielen können
schleswig holstein hat binnen weniger
tage seine position als musterland der
pandemie verloren die instanz liegt bei
530 selbst der ministerpräsident muss
ein empfang der sternsinger absagen
wegen eines corona falls in der
staatskanzlei muss er sich selbst für
zehn tage in quarantäne begeben vier
monate vor der landtagswahl kann er sich
nur per video schalte aus der isolation
melden
stoppen werden wir den incidents anstieg
nur sehr langsam wichtig ist dass die
lage in den krankenhäusern im blick
bleibt und da können sich die menschen
in schleswig holstein darauf verlassen
dass wir da genau so umsichtig als
landesregierung weiter vorgehen werden
wie die menschen das in schleswig
holstein von uns gewöhnt sind weil in
den krankenhäusern wegen vieler
quarantäne fälle das personal knapp wird
werden hier die regeln gelockert damit
konnten allein im westklinikum heide
schon 75 mitarbeitende schneller zurück
zu den patienten ich halte das absolut
führt zu verantworten wir wissen dass
der verlauf bei denen hier anzunehmenden
vielen omikron infektionen so ist das
sehr frühe symptome auftreten am tag 2 3
4 nach der nach dem kontakt wenn wir die
bis dahin nicht haben können wir dann
durch einen pcr-test ausschließen dass
wirklich eine infektion vorliegt alle
mitarbeitenden arbeiten ehe mit sp2
masken dauerbetrieb ich bin da so sicher
mit einer anpassung der regeln an die
wucht der durch das land rollen der
mikrowelle versuchen sie in
schleswig-holstein sicherzustellen dass
der kritischen infrastruktur nicht das
personal ausgeht hier in kiel sind sie
optimistisch bis morgen früh das
fernwärmenetz repariert zu haben das
harmlose grüne farbspektakel wird bald
von ganz alleine verschwinden
seitdem kommune stehen da immer eine
vordersten front sozusagen burkhard jung
ist uns zugeschaltet als
stellvertretender präsident des
deutschen städtetags vertreter die
kommunen und ist selbst zugleich
oberbürgermeister von leipzig guten
abend herr jung und am sonntag wenn es
heißt die kommunen bereiten sich vor auf
mit notfallplänen für die kritische
infrastruktur um sie vor zu vielen
infektionen quarantäne fällen zu
schützen das klingt ja mal ein bisschen
abstrakt wie sehen denn eine solche
notfallpläne aus zum beispiel in leipzig
um sicherzustellen dass da immer genügen
sagen wir mal feuerwehrleute
arbeitsfähig sind wir sind glaube ich
insgesamt gut gewappnet da gibt es
teambildung da gibt es trennungen von
der unterschiedlichen teams da gibt es
bis hin zu möglichkeiten
dass man getrennt
kaserniert wird ein schlechtes wort für
das was eigentlich gemeint ist nämlich
dass man getrennt miteinander versucht
die teams zusammen zu lassen und und
geraten zu lassen und nicht in berührung
kommen zu lassen also insgesamt sind wir
glaube ich jetzt nach zwei jahren
gewartet und gute aufgestellt feuerwehr
stadtwerke wasserwerk stadtreinigung
müllabfuhr ich glaube dass wir insgesamt
gut gelernt haben im jahr fallen eine
ganze menge ein also sie sagt mir gerade
stadtwerke rettungsdienste polizei
krankenhäuser
gesundheitsämter dann natürlich auch die
labors die medizinischen wenn man corona
tests haben will braucht man menschen
die in labors arbeiten
öffentlicher nahverkehr schulen kitas
kann man das wirklich für all diese
bereich mit team bilden und
gegebenenfalls sogar k sanieren um
diesen begriff zu machen als übernehmen
gewährleisten also die kritische
infrastruktur ist natürlich von
besonderer bedeutung
damit menschen im winter nicht frieren
wir haben gerade das beispiel aus kiel
gehört mit der fernwärme aber insgesamt
glaube ich dienen die maßnahmen dazu
dass wir insgesamt handlungsfähig
bleiben die verkürzung der quarantäne
also ich möchte einfach keine panik
verbreiten ich denke dass wir das ganz
gut im griff dass das was in unserer
verantwortung steht auch die polizei das
weiß ich aus gut informierten kreisen
hier bei uns hat sich sehr gut darauf
eingerichtet eingestellt und versucht
die trennung durchzuhalten beim einer
feuerwehr sehe ich das sehr gut in der
in der in den dienstplänen im wie die
teams getrennt miteinander laufen damit
auch wirklich nichts passiert
wirklich keine panik teppich nicht wie
panik waren wir ja auch nicht machen
schon soll es nicht kommen aber man muss
vorbereitet sein will nicht nationen
sagen was ist denn da und teams trennen
die gehen natürlich auch nach hause die
fahren u bahn oder s bahn oder bus man
kann ja nicht die leute alle ständig
parallel laufen lassen das ist so ja das
stimmt am ende wie kann es auch
passieren dass gerade beim fahrzeug
betrieb des öffentlichen nahverkehrs
oder 1&1
besetzung gibt in den fahrzeugen dass es
da vielleicht doch ausfälle gibt und wir
mit vier anderen taktzeiten agieren
müssen aber ich glaube gut daran ist
diesmal dass wir nicht durch eine
bundesweit acht wochen gewartet haben
sollen jetzt im vorfeld von objekten und
agieren ja bedeutet aber auch dass dann
menschen quasi die dienstzeiten
ausbreiten ausweiten müssen also dass
dann urlaub nicht stattfinden
wochenenden die stattfindet erster
kranken den kliniken die gehen ja ich
schon auf dem zahnfleisch ist
also dass das sehe ich ganz wirklich
ganz ganz mit großem respekt was da in
kliniken krankenhäusern geleistet wird
was den gesundheitsämtern in den
ordnungsämtern geleistet wird und in der
tat mit etwas schlechtes gefühl habe ich
dann auch urlaubssperre verhängt oder
um dafür geworben bei unserem
personalräten dass wir auch andere
dienstzeiten akzeptieren aber
insbesondere bei den kliniken ist es
wirklich denn am ende was da auf die
anderen personal nach überhaupt in der
lage ist zu arbeiten kommt dann die
gesundheitsämter eigentlich noch
hinterher in leipzig also vielerorts
weiß man dass ich es nicht mehr tun dass
leute die dann nachdem sie mit viel mühe
irgendwann auch ihren pcr tests bekamen
nach dem sehr positiven selbst testen
symptome hatten dann irgendwann versucht
das amt nur noch einen brief kampeter
begeben sich eine isolierung da waren
die zehn tage eigentlich schon rum ja
das also wir haben 280 gesundheitsämter
in deutschland und die situation ist
sehr unterschiedlich oftmals in großen
städten wird personal seitig unterstützt
wir haben zum beispiel mindestens 250
leute aus der generalverwaltung zu für
der haben bundeswehr unterstützung
gerade in den kritischen tagen der delta
variante hier in sachsen aber das ist
nicht überall der fall wird wird auch in
perspektivisch einfach mehr personal im
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst und das
muss auch finanziert werden über neun
2026 hinaus also das ist so ein thema
das das drückt und dass wir davon zu
kommen sie waren selbst in einem
früheren leben sozusagen lehrer und
schulleiter wenn sie nach frankreich
sehen wo tausende schulklassen jetzt war
sie kollektiv nach hause geschickt
wurden und schulen geschlossen werden
müssen nicht wenn man es wollte oder
politisch wollte weil es einfach nicht
geht wegen der vielen krankheitsfälle
und quarantäne fälle befürchten sie dass
das auch auf leipzig und auf andere
kommunen zukommt ich habe ja immer noch
die große hoffnung dass mein berufsstand
mein ehemaliger berufsstand sich einfach
impfen und boostern lässt und es gibt
dazu wirklich keine alternative und mit
freude habe ich gehört zum beispiel in
leipzig sind die lehrerschaft zu 95
prozent geimpft und gebucht hat und das
gibt mir hoffnung dass man das schaffen
kann bei einigen die impfpflicht dann
endlich dann doch käme eigentlich für
alle darauf setze ich die müssen aus dem
quark kommen in berlin sagt burkhard
jung oberbürgermeister von leipzig und
stellvertretender präsident des
deutschen städtetags ich danken für das
gespräch dann gehe ich jetzt macht
erstmal ein zweiter mit denen
nachrichten und schaut zunächst nach
kasachstan dort sind bei den unruhen der
vergangenen tage nach angaben des
staatsfernsehens
164 menschen getötet wurden 2200 wurden
demnach verletzt
das habe rund 5800 festnahmen gegeben
die lage habe sich mittlerweile beruhigt
in der millionenstadt einmal kamen
unterdessen weitere russische truppen an
die kasachische staatsführung hatte sie
angefordert
verteidigungsministerin lamprecht war
nach dem besuch in jordanien gestern
heute im irak auch dort traf sie
deutsche soldaten
und sie sprach mit ministerpräsident
akademie über die deutsch irakische
zusammenarbeit und die
sicherheitspolitische lage hintergrund
ist eine mögliche verlängerung des ende
januar auslaufenden mandats für den
einsatz der bundeswehr in der region
bundesarbeitsminister heil will die
versprochene erhöhung des mindestlohns
auf 12 euro noch in diesem jahr umsetzen
er werde dazu in den nächsten wochen
einen gesetzentwurf vorlegen sagte der
spd politiker der deutschen presse
agentur die anhebung auf 12 euro haben
sich spd grüne und fdp in den
koalitionsvertrag geschrieben derzeit
liegt der mindestlohn in deutschland bei
9 eur 62 proto pro stunde
in berlin haben heute mehrere hundert
menschen an die kommunistenführer rosa
luxemburg und karl liebknecht erinnert
auf dem friedhof friedrichsfelde kam
auch die spitze der linkspartei zum
traditionellen gedenken darunter die
fraktionsvorsitzenden mohammed ali und
bartsch am 15 januar 1919 waren
luxemburg und liebknecht von
rechtsgerichteten freikorps soldaten
erschossen worden
bei einem feuer in einem wohnhaus in new
york sind mindestens 19 menschen ums
leben gekommen viele menschen wurden
schwer verletzt das bestätigte der
bürgermeister der stadt eric adams dem
sender cnn unter den opfern des unglücks
seien auch neun kinder so ein
feuerwehrsprecher die ursache des
brandes in einem hochhaus mit 19 etagen
im stadtbezirk bronx war zunächst unklar
durch eine herabstürzende felswand sind
im südosten brasiliens mindestens acht
menschen ums leben gekommen mehr als 30
wurden verletzt das unglück ereignete
sich in dem bei touristen beliebten fox
sie im rio grande tonnenschwere
gesteinsbrocken stürzten auf mehrere
boote mit ausflüglern zwei menschen
werden noch vermisst möglicherweise
lösten schwere regenfälle in den
vergangenen tagen den felssturz aus
die letzten gespräche zwischen wladimir
putin und joe biden verliefen ja denkbar
kühl in der kommenden woche soll nun der
dialog wiederbelebt werden morgen
treffen sich vertreter russlands und der
usa in genf am mittwoch tagt erstmals
wieder der nato russland rat in brüssel
hauptkonflikt die ukraine und deren
künftiges verhältnis zur nato
werfen wir doch mal kurz einen blick
zurück ursprünglich war die nato ja ein
reines west bündnis doch nach dem
zusammenbruch der sowjetunion hat sie
sich seit ende der 1990 er jahre immer
mehr nach osten erweitert
aus ehemaligen europäischen
ostblockstaaten wurden mitglieder dem
voraus ging 1997 die nato russland grund
akte die grundsätze für ein
vertrauensvolles miteinander fest
schrieb das funktionierte lange zeit
auch wie sich das verhältnis seit 2008
zusehends verschlechterte je mehr
ehemalige sowjet-republiken interesse an
einem nato-beitritt zeigten mit der
annexion der halbinsel krim durch
russland 2014 spitzte sich der alte neue
ost west konflikt massiv zu die
bestrebungen der ukraine richtung nato
betrachtet russland als bedrohung
befördert aber zugleich durch sein
eigenes verhalten die
sicherheitsbedürfnisse des nachbarlandes
vor allem der hessische truppenaufmarsch
an der grenze zur ukraine schürt ängste
vor einer invasion vor diesem
hintergrund halten die usa auch ein
scheitern der gespräche für möglich
claudia bates berichtet
der mann der den russischen präsidenten
mal einen mörder nannte ist überzeugt
putin versteht nur eine sprache die der
stärke er akzeptiere niemand das rote
linien zu us-präsident beiden
diese bilder sollen den russischen
truppen aufbau zeigen an der
ukrainischen grenze der die usa
alarmiert die regierung nimmt die
situation sehr ernst wie auch putins
forderungen wird aber keine garantien
abgeben
trotz der russischen bedrohung habe die
ukraine selbstverständlich das recht
sich für eine nato mitgliedschaft zu
bewerben es gehe hier um ganz
grundlegende internationale prinzipien
das prinzip dass ein land nicht die
grenzen eines anderen mit gewalt
verändern kann dass kein land einem
anderen seiner außenpolitik und
allianzen diktieren kann das prinzip
dass kein land seine nachbarn
unterwerfen kann diese aggression wird
nicht akzeptiert hatte die russischen
militär bewegungen beantwortet die us
regierung mit der androhung massiver
sanktionen eigene soldaten in den kampf
zu schicken kommt für beiden nicht in
frage
das steht nicht zur debatte würden sie
amerikanische truppen in den krieg
schicken und in der ukraine die russen
auf dem schlachtfeld bekämpfen nein ich
habe präsident putin deutlich klar
gemacht dass wenn er in die ukraine
einmarschiert die wirtschaftlichen
konsequenzen verheerend sein werden
verheerend
bei seinen telefonaten mit putin sei er
sehr deutlich geworden so beiden die
sanktionen würden sofort verhängt sie
würden den energiesektor treffen auch
die nord stream-pipeline wäre wohl
betroffen die größten russischen
finanzinstitute sollen aus dem
internationalen zahlungssystem
ausgeschlossen werden die ukraine würde
weitere waffenlieferungen erhalten die
richtige strategie
wenn der einsatz eigener us-truppen vom
tisch ist müssen andere wege beschritten
werden und das ziel einer deeskalation
führt hoffentlich dazu dass man
verhandeln und eine gemeinsame basis
finden kann ansonsten muss man die
sanktionen einsetzen aber es ist ja gar
nicht klar ob das russland wirklich
steckt
die usa haben jetzt erstmals
kompromissvorschläge durchblicken lassen
raketenstationierung in der region
könnten ebenso begrenzt werden wie
truppenübungen allerdings nur beidseitig
dies hat die russische seite bereits
abgelehnt die expertin nicht überrascht
wir wissen ja nicht ob diese forderungen
von russland gestellt wurden weil sie
wirklich verhandeln wollen um
zugeständnisse zu erzielen oder ob den
russen von vornherein klar war dass der
westen die usa und nato die forderungen
nicht erfüllen können und sie das dann
als vorwand nutzen um in die ukraine
einzumarschieren
die russische delegation trifft hier in
genf ein beide seiten dämpfen bereits
die erwartungen auf einen großen
durchbruch in
europa schaut man nicht nur mit sorge
darauf wie sich das verhältnis zwischen
russland und der ukraine entwickelt und
wie russland in anderen ehemaligen
sowjetrepubliken
interveniert stichwort belarus oder seit
neuestem kasachstan nein auch direkt vor
der haustür der europäischen union gibt
es mit dem balkan noch eine andere
region an der auch russland großes
interesse hat nicht nur weil es dort
russische minderheiten gibt die von
moskau außenpolitische immer gern ins
feld geführt werden die beziehungen
zwischen russen und serben sind
traditionell eng
sorge beobachtet man jedenfalls bei der
eu die wachsenden spannungen im
ehemaligen jugoslawien
insbesondere in bosnien und herzegowina
wolf christian ullrich berichtet
es ist eine machtdemonstration und es
ist eine provokation für jeden der an
die einheit von bosnien und herzegowina
glaubt milorad dodik serbenführer in
bosnien und herzegowina zelebriert hier
den 30 gründungstag der republica srpska
jenen landesteil den er am liebsten vom
rest bosnien und herzegowinas abspalten
würde
unsere freiheit ist unser recht es gibt
für das serbische volk keine freiheit
wenn es keinen serbischen staat hat die
republik als ritzka ist unser staat lang
lebe die republik srpska lang lebe
serbien
[Applaus]
roddicks militär spektakel heute ist
kein zufall er plant eine eigene armee
für die serbische entität er sabotiert
die regierungsarbeit von bosnien und
herzegowina und er arbeitet an einem
gesetzespaket das einen serbischen
parallelstarts schaffen würde seine
anhänger nennen die dinge beim namen
das beste wäre wir werden unabhängig
vielleicht sogar zusammen mit serbien
alles besser als bosnien und herzegowina
wir gehören zu serbien so dass alle
serben in einem land vereint sind
so sieht es aus in der re publica sofsky
dx jahrelanges mantra vom serbischen
nationalstolz hat die ärmlichen
lebensbedingungen hier nicht verbessert
dafür blüht die korruption die folge ein
viertel der bevölkerung hat das land
schon verlassen
auf der parade heute jubeln die armen
serben eine handvoll serbischer
millionäre zu beklagte
oppositionspolitiker wolle mijatovic
dieses land wurde durch korruption
zerstört und das wird jetzt mit flaggen
und national märchen übertüncht
vielleicht hat dodik es jetzt aber zu
weit getrieben die usa haben vor wenigen
tagen finanzsanktionen gegen ihn
erneuert weil er den zerbrechlichen
frieden aufs spiel setze und weil er
korrupt sei und die eu es ist die
sanierung solcher gleisanlagen in der
republica srpska für die dreistellige
millionenbeträge an fördergeldern und
krediten bereit stellt eu parlamentarier
fordern jetzt von der kommission
sanktionen so lange dodik die abspaltung
schiene fährt
die eu sollte klarmachen dass die
finanzielle unterstützung gestoppt wird
wenn du dich sein handeln nicht ändert
auch der hohe repräsentant für bosnien
und herzegowina christian schmid fordert
finanzsanktionen
wichtig ist dass wir den bürgerinnen und
bürger in einer wirtschaftlich
schwierigen lage
unterstützung geben aber klar machen
dass das geld dorthin kommen muss wo es
hin soll
doch de-cix freunde im serbien in
russland und in ungarn hatten ihn
derzeit im geschäft jeder hat dabei
eigene interessen auch dudic profitiert
vom internationalen streit lenkt er doch
davon ab wie desolat die lage in der
republik astra unter seiner führung ist
und jetzt macht nochmal heinz wolf
weiter mit dem sport an diesem
wochenende und zuerst zum fußball
bundesliga hat hertha bsc 1 zu 3 gegen
den ersten fc köln verloren im zweiten
sonntagsspiel gewann bochum gegen
wolfsburg 1 zu 0 die deutsche handball
nationalmannschaft hat am abend ihr
letztes testspiel vor der em gewonnen
gegen olympiasieger und rekord
weltmeister frankreich hieß es am ende
35 zu 34 für das team von bundestrainer
gislason im slalom-weltcup hat es -
straße heute im schweizerischen
adelboden aufs podest geschafft er kam
hinter den österreichern stolz und fälle
auf platz drei und sicherte sich damit
das olympia-ticket für peking
jubel bei linus strasser nach einer
furiosen und zugleich kontrollierten
aufholjagd ich habe es geschafft einfach
den schienen am laufen zeiten keine
riesen fehler zu machen adelboden und
strasser das passt im vergangenen jahr
von platz 12 nach dem ersten lauf auf
zwei vorgefahren diesmal bei schwierigen
bedingungen von 14 auf platz drei
schnellster vor 10.000 zuschauern im
schweizer adelboden der österreicher
johannes strolz mit seinem ersten
weltcup-sieg im jahr schon in der schule
gegangen zwei jahre lang also ich kenne
den namen schon ewig lang hab mir
unglaublich spaß gemacht von jahren als
auch mit dem schulfreund aufs podium
olympia-norm geknackt ein perfekter
sonntag für adelboden experte - straße
mit einem weiteren erfolg im viererbob
sicherte sich francesco friedrich heute
in winterberg vorzeitig den weltcup
gesamtsieg einen doppel erfolg gab es
für die deutschen frauen laura nolte
siegte im zweier vor teamkollege und
seinen achten weltcupsieg vor wenzels
geiger bei den nordischen kombinierern
als zehnter im springen setzte sich
geiger in der loipe von weil die firma
kurz vor dem ziel von den verfolgern ab
die hamburger feiern seit heute fünf
jahre elbphilharmonie die alfie ist aus
dem stadtbild ja längst nicht mehr
wegzudenken eigentlich kann man sich
kaum noch vorstellen wie es ohne sie war
das müssen architekten auch erst mal
schaffen ein so ikonisches gebäude zu
entwerfen das zum neuen wahrzeichen
einer stadt und darüber wie seinerzeit
bauzeit und kosten explodierten redet
man zum jubiläum lieber nicht dabei ist
das auch ein prägnantes beispiel dafür
wie politisches wunschdenken und
realistische projektplanung
auseinanderdriften doch heute durfte
einfach nur gefeiert werden vom
festkonzert berichtet sven ricke
ludwig van beethoven wollte eigentlich
ein klavierkonzert schreiben es wurde
eine sinfonie seine achte hamburgs
philharmonisches staatsorchester
gratuliert damit der elbphilharmonie zum
fünften geburtstag
aus der skandalbaustelle ist auch etwas
großes geworden ein konzerthaus das
gleichzeitig ein statement ist ich
glaube es ist noch mal viel weiter von
konsum- oder von erfolg von ziffern es
ist ökologisch und und von seele sehr
sehr wichtig dass wir in hamburg führen
dass wir durch den kunst noch mehr
relevanz haben für zukunft
die elbphilharmonie ist eine investition
in die zukunft musik für alle
generationen
die ersten fünf jahre eine playlist mit
allen zutaten 1600 konzerte in einem
saal der hellhörig und direkt ist und in
dem jeder alles hört
[Applaus]
man sagt ja liebe macht blind und ich
liebe diesen saal aber liebe macht nicht
taub und als musiker jahr schätze ich
gerade diese sensibilität des raumes der
wirklich alles überträgt und sehr
plastisch darstellt das ist im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert eminent
wichtig dass wir diese frischen
lebendigen neuen
begegnungsstätten schaffen um eben auch
ein publikum anzuziehen dass sich in
diesem sowieso sehr tradierten rahmen
etwas unwohl fühlt
unwohlsein ein gefühl das die geschichte
der elbphilharmonie noch heute auslöst
die eiszeit zwischen stadt architekten
und baukonzern brachte eineinhalb jahre
baustopp erst ein neuer vertrag und eine
feste bausumme lösten den knoten
789 millionen euro die hamburger
anfängen von der lp zu träumen waren es
77 die bilder deutschlands in der welt
früher war da fotos von neuschwanstein
vom brandenburger tor und vom kölner dom
damit ist ein bericht über deutschland
illustriert worden da taucht jetzt
regelhaft die elbphilharmonie auf das
ist schön weil es im gebäude im norden
ist weil es im gebäude aus 21
jahrhundert ist das in einer demokratie
entstanden ist und ein gebäude der
kultur ist das unterscheidet sich von
allen drei anderen häusern dann ja doch
schon erheblich
zur bilanz gehören 3,3 millionen konzert
und fast 15 millionen besucher auf der
öffentlichen plaza ein grund zum feiern
trotz pandemie das konzerthaus liegt
bereits auf platz zwei hamburg it liste
gleich nachdem
eine strahlkraft die offensichtlich bis
in die tiefsee reicht zumindest im web
handle bot der philharmonie
und dann schauen wir noch auf die
nächste woche den wochenausblick liefert
heute anna kaiser
[Musik]
am mittwoch wird der bundestag mit der
regierungsbefragung ins neue jahr
starten erstmals wird kanzler olaf
scholz den abgeordneten rede und antwort
stehen im anschluss werden bis freitag
alle fachminister innen dem bundestag
die wichtigsten pläne ihrer häuser
vorstellen damit will die ampel
koalition ein signal des aufbruchs
senden am donnerstag wird in koblenz der
weltweit erste strafprozess um starts
folter in syrien enden vor gericht
stehen zwei mutmaßliche mitarbeiter des
syrischen geheimdienstes
sie sollen menschen im bürgerkriegsland
gefoltert haben ein urteil ist bereits
gefallen nun soll das zweite folgen
am selben tag wird novi sad in serbien
offiziell europäische
kulturhauptstadt bis zum ende des jahres
sollen 5000 europäische künstler innen
unter dem motto brücken bauen in die
stadt kommen auch esche luxburg und
kaunas in litauen sind dieses jahr
kulturhauptstadt
und noch der blick aufs wetter zum start
in die neue woche morgen im südosten
fällt etwas schnee oder regen sonst ist
es freundlich teils auch stärker bewölkt
aber meist trocken die höchsttemperatur
liegt zwischen minus zwei und plus 6
grad und so ähnlich geht es dann auch
weiter mal scheint die sonne mal ist es
trüb aber regen oder schnee gibt es kaum
die temperaturen liegen zwischen minus
zwei und plus 9 grad
eher schmuddelig das war es von uns für
noch ein bisschen sonntägliche sofa
gemütlichkeit sorgt jetzt inspektor
bundle und um 0.30 gibt es dann die
nächste express und morgen abend freut
sich hier ein neues team auf sie
christian sievers und hanna zimmermann
noch einen schönen abend doch wieder
sind
[Musik]